let's wrap this back to the the media
aspect of it all because when you know
cnn lies and the mainstream press lie
over and over again one of the outlets
that we have is social media however as
most everybody knows one of the biggest
stories of our generation the hunter
biden laptop scandal was censored by
twitter they literally on facebook they
literally blocked sharing of this link
even in private messages
likely just to help joe biden win the
election polling from s museum and a
couple other outlets came out showing
that people i think by like seven
percentage points would have not voted
for joe biden had they known about the
laptop scandal and the things that joe
biden had been doing
and oh well with that being said we have
this story here uh most of you may have
heard this is one of the biggest stories
in a long time jack dorsey is resigning
as twitter ceo
board member and former chief technology
officer parag agrawal has been appointed
ceo effective immediately
you know
jack dorsey is a hypocrite
he's either well he's a hypocrite he's a
liar i believe or he's just completely
inept
so
when i when i was talking to jack and
i've talked to him several times since i
met him on the jorgen podcast
he was talking about a path to
redemption for those that get banned you
can't make you know a life sentence
because you said a naughty word or
whatever he talked about solving the
problem and bringing about
decentralization and what did he do
after all these years literally nothing
but quit and appoint someone who is as
woke or woker than he is
this new guy
the chief technology officer agrawal
he's got this interview
where i mean it's gone viral he
basically says let me see if i can pull
it up they ask him about it and let me
uh let me make sure i can pull up the
part where he talks about the first
amendment
he's asked about free speech on twitter
so we can expect things to get a whole
lot worse
he says you're caught in a bit of a hard
place this is the interviewer litchfield
as somebody in the audience is also
pointing out that you're trying to
combat misinformation you also want to
protect free speech as a core value and
also in the us as the first amendment
how do we balance those two he said our
role is not to be bound by the first
amendment but our role is to serve a
healthy public conversation and our
moves are uh are reflective of things
that we believe lead to a healthier
public conversation the kinds of things
that we do about this is focused less on
thinking about free speech but thinking
about how the times have changed one of
the changes today that we see is speech
is easy on the internet most people can
speak where our role is particularly
emphasized is who can be heard the
scarce commodity today is attention
there's lots of content out there a lot
of tweets out there not all of it gets
attention some subset of it gets
attention and so increasingly our role
is moving towards how we recommend
content and that sort of is a struggle
that we're working through in terms of
how we make sure these recommendation
systems that we're building how we
direct people's attention in leading to
a healthy public conversation that is
most participatory
uh code word for we know what's better
for you than you do and we're gonna make
sure that conversations we deem to be
the healthy ones are had and promoted
and your ideas aren't and let's be real
they directly remove news stories that
are bad for their psychotic goals and
agendas and i want to give a shout out
real quick to project veritas who has
those undercover videos of bernie
sanders supporters and democrat staffers
talking about being violent and
manipulating people and talking about
gulags
because if you ever talk to these antifa
people in private they will straight up
tell you they intend to kill millions of
people and i'm not exaggerating i'm not
trying to push hyperbole i mean
literally go to these meetings
and they will calmly these antifa far
leftists calmly and rationally say
things like you know if we want
communism we have to reconcile with the
fact there's going to be you know tens
of millions of people who will actively
resist many of whom will violently
resist to uphold
capitalism white supremacy insert
buzzword and they'll say well those
people have to be sent to the gulags to
break rocks to understand what hard work
really means
many of whom will die
when you see stories like this and
you've got psychotic ego maniacal
lunatics like this guy agrawal and jack
dorsey saying we know what's healthy not
you you don't get to speak
what do you think what do you think the
future will look like under that kind of
person well
we were already in that spot with with
ceo jack dorsey but i gotta be honest
jack dorsey didn't do a whole lot and he
still was willing to go on shows and
talk to people this guy i think is going
to be much more locked down much more
robotic pr oriented just garbage
statements put out lies manipulation
and
as much as i think twitter is trash it
does still have that opportunity to
spread news outside the mainstream
whereas cnn is is it is a pollutant i
know you know with with you guys at
white coat getting these stories out
probably is difficult because i don't
think cnn would go near anything that
smears fouchy
no it's been hard to get mainstream
media coverage for anything criticizing
fauci particularly in this
administration
we've taken them on before under
trump a lot of these
news outlets were happy to cover us
beating up the administration and now
they're not anymore
twitter is actively banning ads right
now from us wow criticizing fauci we
were trying to run our dogs against
fouchy ads about him funding uh deadly
maximum pain experiments on dogs and
twitter dogs too yeah twitter banned
those ads they won't give us a blue
check either
so we were hoping things would get
better when jack left but it doesn't
sound like it i don't think jack was
that was really the ceo at this point
anyway i think they panicked i think who
was the ceo before him was it dick
estolo i don't know i don't remember but
uh i think they had a crisis
they were like bring jack dorsey back on
because he was a co-founder and it'll
look really really good you know to our
investors or whatever and then jack just
basically made a bunch of boring
nonsensical ideological public
statements and never actually
implemented anything
i mean this is going to be a very
interesting uh transition of power i
believe because i think there's going to
be some kind of difference that we're
going to be feeling with this uh kind of
transition there's this new guy coming
in he also has ties to of course snopes
and politifact so it's going to be
interesting to see how he implements
this a lot of people are bringing up his
old tweet from 2010 where he talked
about if you're gonna talk about muslims
being all extremists then you should you
shouldn't distinguish between white
people and racists of course there's a
lot of different contexts behind that it
was a long time it was a quote from the
daily show yeah it was from asif manvi
yeah but but honestly you know i never
thought i would say this and i'm
actually going to defend jack dorsey
here a little bit if you compare now
what twitter is to facebook and
instagram it is way better especially
when it comes to censorship of speech
now that doesn't say much that's like
comparing like uh uh you know the devil
to to you know a different smaller devil
but you know like lucifer i was gonna
say it's still the devil it's still evil
but uh i've personally noticed having a
lot more fun and a lot more freedom on
twitter than i would on instagram and
facebook because i've been getting fact
checked a lot more on facebook and
instagram than i have on twitter and
there's a lot of stuff i get away with
on twitter that i would naturally not
get away with now of course i could be
mixed in the crowd i could not be
targeted a lot of people have been
targeted a lot of people have had their
speech uh aggressively limited which is
absolutely horrible tim you got
something to say well it's it's not that
twitter's better it's that they're all
different facebook is the worst by far
because they ban everything they put
fake fact checks on things they empower
political actors to lie about statements
you know i've made or you make yeah
youtube is actually decent in some areas
but really really bad in terms of
general censorship twitter is good in
some areas but really really bad in
terms of censorship sure you know
twitter allows you to talk about a lot
of things like fauci and the vaccines if
you're just tweeting but what you don't
know is when they shadow ban you and
then you got to do a check or they won't
verify certain people they won't verify
uh you know actually i think they banned
james o'keefe completely right so yeah
they wouldn't verify him there's a lot
of people they won't verify and that
verification is a sign of credibility
and they know it and trust
now youtube allows you to say some
things but youtube is worse than twitter
so i think it's it's fair to point out
they're all bad but if like i was going
to give a censorship score where a
positive score means your pro free
speech and a negative score means you
oppose free speech then you know
facebook is like a negative 93 and
youtube is a negative 65 and then
twitter is a negative you know 47.
they're all opposed to free speech like
a 43 or 50 maybe but i'm along the same
lines but it's still one of the still
one of the places where you could share
a lot of controversial ideas without
having the ban hammer instagram i know
oh i'm going to post this i'm going to
get banned i'm going to get hit right
away i i just know so so there's also
something interesting happening with
jack dorsey tweeting a lot of very
curious stuff he tweeted out murray's
rothbard's book
anatomy of the state uh recently as well
he's really into bitcoin so i don't know
maybe he got surprise dosed and had some
kind of revelation there's also rumors
of him having a shake-up an argument
with elliot management that's the hedge
fund that's pretty much uh has a
substantial stake in twitter so i
wouldn't be surprised if there were some
bigger moves here made uh jack dorsey
also just previously said a couple
months ago if he wasn't working at
twitter he would be working in bitcoin
so uh just the fact that he has promoted
bitcoin as much as he can that he even
tweeted out murray's rothbard's book is
is pretty huge so there might be some
kind of
waking up or some kind of internal
conflict that we don't even know about
that has caused this larger shake-up
which i do believe there's going to be
some ramifications of maybe maybe uh you
know i don't want to take the just the
direct pessimistic view of this guy as a
do-nothing hypocrite maybe the reality
is there is a lot of stuff that jack
dorsey talked about doing with bitcoin
with crypto with decentralization and
maybe he just couldn't do it maybe they
wouldn't let him do it maybe they said
it's bad for our bottom line so no and
he eventually said okay i'm going to
leave and go do it.
so maybe he'll work in blockchain
technology he told me this years ago he
said
that you know we need decentralized
blockchain social media that's immutable
and i said that's a really bad idea
because that means someone could post my
address and it could never be deleted
and i would not be happy with you know
that private information or you know
personal images or something like that
there needs to be a way to remove that
stuff and he was like okay well i see
your point but decentralized social
media is way better and i said that we
agree on but in all these years he's
never gotten any of that done so maybe
he's just completely ineffective and it
was a waste of time from even bother at
twitter maybe we shouldn't give the man
the benefit of the doubt because he's
never proven anything he's done has was
in in the right direction in terms of
helping people on the social media
platform i thought square was pretty
cool i don't know too much about it that
other company that he started in 2009 he
basically left twitter in 2010 resigned
as ceo started square which was like a
financial app and then uh they brought
him back for the face game to look nice
i would love to interview him if we
could get him to sit down and talk about
i mean he probably won't be able to even
talk about the inner drama that happened
with a lot of the bigger players behind
twitter because twitter has a lot of big
players twitter it also has a lot of
saudi arabian investment so there's
there's a lot of you know things
happening behind the doors that we don't
even know about that i wish i could be a
fly on the wall when they're discussing
a lot of these issues but uh we'll see
what he does after this i mean i think
he's going to be going into the bitcoin
realm i think it's very easy to say that
he said that before so it's going to be
interesting to see where he goes from
here and i mean i would just love to
talk to him to be honest with you i'm
gonna dm them right now yeah that'd be
awesome be like hey do you want to come
and have a conversation about um what's
going on here we want to give you a fair
play to address yourself and and talk
about your larger projects i think i
would love to question him on a lot of
different stuff
but uh we'll see what he's able to say
and what he's not able to say i think
all this stuff from this new ct ceo the
former cto i think um it really smacks
of this rank elitism because talking
about how we know what's best for you
just it looks exactly like it's
currently the science community talking
about we know what's best for you and
even when people are actively being hurt
by some of these things that they're
pushing through they're like we still
know what's best for you you have no say
in your life you don't know what's right
and thomas soul talks about this too he
talks about how we're entrusting a lot
of society to people who pay no price
for being wrong somebody pointed out on
twitter earlier today they were like um
it's really interesting that we lock
down that millions of people are like
out of work that people are committing
suicide left right and center and the
only people who are paying no price for
this are the people who
put it into place like that doesn't seem
right but this is just just disgusting
elitism i think it's something for the
first amendment someone commented on my
facebook because i said something i
don't know was it about it was probably
about like lockdowns or australia and
they were just like i wonder what occupy
tim would be saying about tim today he'd
probably be he'd probably be saying
things like oh you got really into guns
everything else seems to be all right
like freedom liberty free speech like
when i was down at occupy defending
people's right to free speech i'm like
it's for the same reason i don't agree
with their politics but like by all
means do your protest complain about the
elites but i bring that up because of
what you were saying about the elites
here we are as a show that gets smeared
or we get insulted we get smeared they
claim we're right wing or whatever which
whatever that means and we're literally
like the one percent raw you know the
elites are ripping us off steve bannon
comes on the show and he's like you
gotta tax the rich man and i was like
steve that's a far left position you
know like it's not the conservative or
the right wing that wants to do that and
he's like well you know the billionaires
are ripping you off and i'm like
all right like
i'm down and i think the that's the
thing about the media that's why social
media decentralization is so important
cnn's going to lie to you msnbc is going
to lie msnbc boy do they lie i mean come
on brian williams that was brian
williams right he made up that fake
story about being shot at yeah yeah and
then they were like move them to msnbc
because those people don't care if
they're lied to yeah yeah that's crazy
so we need to have a space where we can
actually challenge the system the funny
thing about this is you know like i
mentioned here we are challenging and
questioning the elites and the
establishment steve bannon did the same
thing and there were people watching the
show being like whoa
i didn't know that was bannon's position
because the media had lied so much about
him saying he's like a white supremacist
and a racist and all that stuff when in
reality he's just a general populist
he's not even he calls himself far right
but i'm like you're just a populist yeah
like there's left and right wing
positions in what you're saying it's not
even i'm like i think one of the things
is
if with the left if we
maybe we should do this we should invite
a leftist populist to come on the show
with steve bannon so we can hear them
say i agree the entire show and just
break the the narrative seriously kyle
kalinski you want to come on the show
with steve bannon we think you think
that'd be cool yeah and then have them
talk about all the things they agree on
and be like oh wow we agree on so much
stuff that sounds different media was
lying about this i i wonder if i mean
you know the thing about left populist
is they have their own shows to do for
the most part so it's always hard to be
like stop doing your show come do my
show but um i'm sure there are some left
populists who would be interested in
coming on and having a conversation yeah
i mean if it wasn't for big tech social
media if it wasn't for the corporate
media we would figure out that we have a
lot more in common than we do
that's dividing us i think there is a
larger divide and conquer agenda i think
there's even things made up to divide us
whether it's sex and gender or beliefs
or ideologies i think a lot of it is
interjected in a way where it's divisive
and it's divisive on purpose so of
course we keep fighting each other
instead of realizing the larger bigger
players out there who are screwing
everyone else over literally committing
one of the largest transfers of wealth
in recorded human history which is
ongoing right now because of this
pandemic which of course is creating a
new billionaire class that is becoming
richer than ever and everyone else is
getting screwed over i had uh what was
that guy's name who was a part of the
trump administration peter navarro yeah
he was on here he called me a bernie
supporter
i felt i felt so offended so offended
but he probably came from that
perspective after he heard a lot of my
critiques of the kind of ruling
establishment because a lot of people
correlate the two but you know the i'm
it's further from the truth but if i
would say on a political spectrum i
probably have a lot of issues that a lot
of
bernie supporters would probably agree
with me on if they were able to hear me
out if they were able to talk to me if
they were able to have a real honest
conversation um and i think that's what
a lot of people are afraid of they're
afraid of people sitting down having
that real conversation being able to
discuss their differences in a way
that's peaceful and respectful because
when you do that you break down all the
things that are of course are screwing
people over and conning them into this
left right divide and conquer game i
think
if we ask steve
bannon
uh like if like we got him with
kalkalinski he'd probably just be like
yes right off the bat yeah he probably
think it was fun but i think kyle would
probably be like let me think about it
yeah of course so i'll just i don't know
and i you know i think it's maybe
because you know bannon i think is
wealthy enough to be like sure we'll do
it and kyle's got to you know right
full-time job's got to do a show but i
also i i don't think kyle is the kind of
person who would play you know stupid
games like a lot of a lot of new grifter
types on the left or the right would do
the right always wants to come on for a
debate no matter who they are but a lot
of people left are worried about cancel
culture and stuff i just want to say
this real quick before we go to the next
story kyle kalinski
big fan
come on the show with steve bannon we'll
set it up and i think it'll be an
awesome conversation and we'll just
we'll we'll try and we'll talk through
all these issues about where we agree
where we disagree i think would be
fascinating right everybody agree
absolutely yeah that's so funny
absolutely
yeah kyle's red he had a tweet where he
was like i just want a democrat that's
not ultra woke and isn't gonna you know
bend like bow down to the media and i'm
like
yes yes yes of course and someone said
isn't that just democrat trump and i'm
like look maybe you get if we had if we
had a democrat who wasn't just falling
in line with pelosi and the rest of the
party who actually was like hey i'm kind
of more to the left and the republicans
but we agree on what the truth is we
think the media is full of it the ultra
work stuff is crap i'd be like all right
you know here we're getting somewhere i
think tulsi gabriel was very much like
that and they called her right wing so
now sudden people are tweeting that kyle
kalinski was turning into jimmy dore
what and i was like
then look if if dave rubin was on the
left and now he's on the right and jimmy
dore was on the left now on the right
and kyle kalinski's going that direction
maybe you need to start looking at your
boot for what the crap really is because
it's not other people if you're not
smelling it yeah and they keep attacking
people who realize that we have a lot
more in common who try to bridge the
gaps a lot of leftists who don't always
believe in the cult don't always drink
the kool-aid they're the ones that get
attacked the most viciously by their own
side so seeing that happen is is also
very frustrating because you see a lot
of people play up to the mob and try to
be popular and try to play up to their
audience members or their comments
section and you should never do that
because a lot of it is gamed a lot of it
is manipulated a lot of it is played to
emotionally and mentally control you in
so many different ways thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time